[Music]
you want a podcast
i got a smart cat you want a podcast i
got a smart cat
you want a podcast i got a smart cat you
wanna you wanna if you wanna
you
[Music]
kevin smith
[Music]
now uh you mentioned before you
eventually went off and did your thing
in a world where you didn't think you
know
the albums would go to the front of the
store to let alone the top of the charts
let alone into legendary iconic
legacy position in the world of music
you didn't see yourself
becoming an actor but then it happened
when did you start was it
while you were acting in other people's
movies is that when you were like you
know
i can do this as well when do you get
the idea for friday
uh [ __ ] from john singleton
you know i was with him at his house he
had just bought a a new house in baldwin
hills
and i went over there to see him i would
go over there and watch movies you know
he would he'd put me through film school
and [ __ ] like
we would watch and see what's good
movies what's bad movies
he showed me [ __ ] like a clockwork
orange and
uh you know stanley kubrick
um 2001 space odyssey and [ __ ] like that
he would like
you know just show me what was a good
movie versus a bad movie and why
and then one day uh
i just popped over and he looked at me
one day he was like man
when you gonna write a script
i was like damn john um i'm just now
trying to learn how to act man
you know let alone write a [ __ ]
script he was like man
i'm gonna hear that [ __ ] he said if you
can write them kind of records
i know you can write a script
that day i left his house me and ken we
went down
to it was a [ __ ] mac store on
like in century city right there in like
santa monica or some [ __ ] we went right
there
i bought a mac computer i bought
final draft i didn't know what the hell
i was doing
i just went home and i just started
writing
a script it was [ __ ]
don't get you wow
but he helped me through this clunky way
of writing you know
no no just kind of just off the dumb i
didn't know
i don't really know how to do it so he
worked with me and um
the script was readable it wasn't great
but it was readable
how cl was it friday and i got the book
was that script friday or no no no it
was a script called
america eats is young where is it where
is it
it's uh it's probably somewhere buried
on one of my laptops around here
somewhere
do you ever want to do you ever want to
revisit it as the first thing that you
wrote
no it's garbage it's not good
not good i know then i wrote a script
called uh defense with a guy named floyd
matrix
and um he he's the guy who wrote some of
the first teaching chong movies
and um that you know i learned the
process a little better working with a
bonafide writer you know john is a
is a is a writer director so he's
writing
direct this guy writes just right you
know
knowing that it's gonna be handed off to
somebody else yeah
yeah so he i learned the process
you know by writing that second script
and then the third script i wrote
was friday with me and dj poop
you know we was uh we was fans of the
chicha chong
movies fans of hollywood shuffle
i love hollywood shuffle nobody ever
talks about robert townsend's movie man
yeah
yeah brilliant robert townsend winky
dick
brilliant movie he was one of the people
responsible for
event me eventually doing what i do
because i remember hearing him
interviewed by howard stern when i was
still like working
at the convenience store well that might
have been when i was still
in high school because i have this vague
memory of me being in the
parking lot of the school but it was him
talking about
putting credit card his movie on credit
cards
yeah that was the first time i'd ever
heard that notion i was like what and i
was young
and it was years before i would ever
make a movie but i was like
that's possible you could do that sort
of thing and it went and
stored in the memory bank so that years
later when i was like i'm gonna try to
make a movie i'm gonna put on credit
cards
i pulled directly from that dna because
i knew it had successfully been done
before and i love that movie that movie
is hysterical i mean robert townsend
you wouldn't have friday without robert
townsend is that right
yeah because of the inspiration you know
his inspiration
and doing hollywood shuffle the way he
did it and how good it was
i mean i plucked john witherspoon
from seeing you know he used to do he
used to do these hbo
comedy specials too you know i think
called the yeah undercover bro you know
it was like some kind of uh
robert townsend's you know uh
yeah criminal yeah it was like memories
of that
the cover of the box the vhs yeah you
know you have
the trees rushing and [ __ ] coming out
doing the music
and uh so you know
him doing that kind of stuff uh kanan
doing
and living color like all these inspired
me and me and uh me and pooh
to write friday also like
boys in the hood minister society south
central
colors like everybody thought living
how we grew up was just pure hell
like it was no it was like no
fun so me and pooh was like man wait a
minute we had fun growing up let's
let's show how we would envision this
kind of [ __ ] going down in our
neighborhood
you know um so
that was a big draw too to show south
central wasn't
all bullets and warzone even though it
is
[ __ ] drive-by shootings in friday but
it was uh the tone of having fun
through all the chaos and not you know
it could have been a heavy drama you
know friday could have actually been a
heavy [ __ ] drama you got
you know the neighborhood dope dealer
want to kill us and [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
um but we we we wanted to flip that and
uh we actually was like
this [ __ ] got to be hood but it got to
feel like home alone
you gotta you gotta have that fun
bright i wanna be there feel
you know i'm not dread drab
i'm ready to run out the [ __ ] theater
you know what i'm saying
it's a wonderful uh hysterical flick
where where did chris tucker come to it
um it's a trip because
uh nobody wanted chris tucker in the
movie really
really what what year is this who was
supposed to play smokey
poo dj pooh was supposed to you guys
wrote it together yeah yes
uh new line when new line
acquired the script
they they said well you know that's a
lot of
dialogue for somebody we met we don't
even know
you know who never acted before you know
he was never
he did it a few of my videos but that
was it
so they pushed real hard on you got to
find a co-star
you know they was actually talking about
you know tommy davidson and people like
that
uh who you know he was hot at the time
um
i said no i want an unknown i won't i
don't want you to know who this person
is really
because i want him to be smokey when you
see him [ __ ] smokey nobody else
you know what i'm saying so i didn't
want none of the known comedians that
was already hot
but i had seen chris tucker on
death comedy jam and then
they put him in house party three but
they gave him like
tiny park i said oh they [ __ ] up
that kid right there is a star so
i pushed him on the studio made him fly
him out get
audition f gary gray was even like man
why who is this kid i don't know man i
don't know i don't know i don't know
i said let us just audition together
because the [ __ ] i seen him doing tv if
he could do that here
it's a wrap and once we got down
together
they saw the chemistry they saw
i mean everything he said was funny
and that's how he got the part
um you know
i fought for him to get it because i i
knew
you know i just knew that this is the
kind of kid that i want to play next to
me because he reminded me of
some of the dudes in our neighborhood
that was crazy you know
yeah what so first produced screenplay
third screenplay written first produced
screenplay
and produces a like uh instant
classic with phraseology that enters
into the pop culture
lexicon and beyond the pop culture
lexicon
the lexcom there are people that say bye
felicia don't even know why they say it
yeah without a doubt i i gotta give
credit to pat charbonnet too if you look
at the credits
you'll see pat charbonnet she was my
manager at the time
and she was the one who really
you know the script was you know
very pregnant right
she helped us get it into shape
um helped us find the financing
with new line uh and help produce the
movie
you know so you know she's an unsung
hero on this friday
um you know i guess
i'll call it legacy or
classic movie you know so
without her you don't get you don't get
the movie as
tight as it is are you going back
in is there another friday in our future
well i'm actually trying to get the
movie out of warner brothers
is that what i saw i saw something i had
popped up in my feet so
what what's the idea
they [ __ ] around
you know in this new line it's toby
emerick over there
well he runs warner brothers now but it
was just a new line
[ __ ] uh you know me and new line only
together
of course they got the rights to put
this [ __ ] [ __ ] out so
the end of the day i wrote
two crazy scripts like
for the last friday one day
they just wouldn't do um
you know it was before cannabis was
legal right
so it was about uh it was about
it was right in that era where it was
state but the feds were still [ __ ]
with the dispensary so
smoky in and uh not smokey but
craig and daddy they had a dispensary
and [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] got they had a
flash mob in there stole all the [ __ ]
and you know we ended up [ __ ] up some
kids and they're going to jail
in jail we see all the [ __ ]
that we put there from the joker
brothers to debo
to damon and our whole thing is was
trying to survive in [ __ ] jail
with these [ __ ] like locked in
with us
then we sent to a rehab to rehab
you know i had smokey run in the rehab
and it's a [ __ ] scam it's [ __ ]
you know they just back there smoking
all the dope they find on people
so you know it was uh it was to me great
for the time
and then [ __ ] was like well
this
this is before like any of these shows
that come
after this but yeah they're spending too
much time in jail
nobody you know jail's not really funny
you know you know all this [ __ ] then
after that all these
[ __ ] shows come out like let's go to
jail orange is the new black
all this [ __ ] come out i'm like you
[ __ ]
z you were i was ahead of the curve
finger on the pulse
blow me now so that was the first [ __ ]
up
so i wrote a whole nother script that
was
perfect i mean
and for whatever reason they was like
well
uh the love story part i don't really
understand
i'm like you don't understand what the
[ __ ] what are you worried about the love
story part
that [ __ ] is my nude in this whole story
it's so small
what are you holding up a whole [ __ ]
franchise for
dialogue basically you know what i'm
saying so
it was all [ __ ] this paul you know
stalls star
star then john witherspoon
passes away rest in peace
and then tiny passes away so i want the
[ __ ] movie back
you know i just want my [ __ ] back and i
can go
make my movie they just don't know what
the [ __ ] they doing
and it and this is the same studio that
wouldn't do straight out of compton they
let you they get
they turned it over universal because
they thought it was just a rap movie
and they wouldn't do ride along
because they didn't think me and kevin
hart could do a hidden movie together
so they had ride along for [ __ ] 10
years
are you kidding me they let universal
half down so
[ __ ] they don't know what the [ __ ] they
doing what are your
what are your sorry what are your
chances of
getting it out
great [ __ ] you know um
i mean especially if they're not gonna
move forward with it
let's go back to the fact that the first
script you wrote
just should have been greenlit
predicated on how much money
you've previously made the studio with
the other fridays
so right then and there like you walk in
with the script
you know as long as it's it's uh
i mean really like this is a sequel to
[ __ ] friday
there should be no boundaries and as the
creator of the material it's like if
you're like
it's in jail then they should have just
been like they wanted to tell me what
needs to be in the friday movie
that's and how did that feel i mean how
nuts is that
it don't make crazy man sense
um they it seems silly
because it feels like they're just
leaving money on the table
they are and and so hopefully
um they either come to their senses and
be like just go
here go or they're like you know what
take it god bless but it doesn't it's
not a good look to hold on to it and not
do something no
man you know they i said they holding
the happiness of the culture hostage
that's a good line that's good well and
they are boy you're good with you're
good with the words man you should
write lyrics or something like that day
one day that is uh that's frustrating
but i hope to god it works out for you
but i'll tell you this much
i'm gonna like it's not i wouldn't call
the schadenfreude or whatever but like
it makes me like at my level which is
way below your level
it makes me go like jesus it's hard up
there
like i would just assume you walk in and
you're like
it has it it's it doesn't it's you don't
even get
day out you're like fry and they're like
here's the [ __ ] money go
go go because you could just keep doing
it like you know as long as people
were interested particularly the
creators and and the original cast
so it was [ __ ] up kevin is
they beg me to write these things and
then don't make them
and then don't [ __ ] make them so
i don't know what i don't know what it
is you know it just seemed
it's very uh strange
can't put my finger on it um
you know you know at the end of the day
they just [ __ ] with me you know i'm
saying you know you
they bug the [ __ ] out of us for me to
write these things
i wrote two scripts and they sat on
their hands for no reason
to go time to go for heaven sex i
wouldn't do a movie with the
[ __ ] from nothing in the world
and you uh you have been this is warner
brothers
because new lines water brothers owned
by warner brothers
and you had a brother and you had been
in warner brothers stuff three kings of
the warner brothers movie right
yeah i've been in a few of the movies i
mean
a few of the movies you know it's like i
don't understand
you know what they thinking but
it's not working for me
um can i ask you a off-topic question
just because it came up and i was like
oh [ __ ]
and i'm just stoned enough to ask on
three kings
there was that story that george clooney
punched the director were you there
it was no punches throng there were no
punches phone
no but you were so you were yes
intense head-to-head
i'm about to [ __ ] you up kind of that
kind of energy like let's go let's go
but nobody actually threw nobody threw a
punch
um had you ever seen that sort of
intensity on a movie before
um
no not between the director and the
actor that wasn't
that big that would have scared me off
forever i would have been like oh
i never want to see that that ain't [ __ ]
man
man i don't see crazier [ __ ] than that
is that right that was entertaining
that was what entertaining entertaining
you've seen like like directors and
actors like really get into it or
no i just seen people get into it you
know like [ __ ] at events
oh like in real life not on real life
that's true
somebody get into it on the set ain't
gonna do nothing you know what i'm
saying
long as they keep that [ __ ] over there
totally um
i hope you get it back again it just
makes no sense
for them to let an asset that they know
will print money it's not even like
man i don't know if we want to take a
risk on this friday picture it's like
they know it's going to make money no
matter what it is
but you know the if the creator of the
material says this is what it is
just go take the journey like
you know john witherspoon died
uh waiting on this movie uh
hoping dreaming wishing to do this movie
uh not only him you know you got
all the comedians when they do a friday
movie
it gives them a bump for five six years
man
you know um so it's just
it's sad for these people to just sit on
this material
and uh let great you know stars that we
love
pass away tiny lister passed away you
know it's about
seven seven people from the friday
franchises that
that's no longer with us so to me
it's just uh you know it's almost time
to take this [ __ ] to court
um yeah do it get yours
get it back for heaven's sakes those are
your characters man
think about it and uh that's and but
also
like you're right the heartbreaking
aspect is
like we won't get john witherspoon
because somebody yeah somebody
dilly-dallied because somebody was like
wow
this ain't friday to the guy who made
friday
man crazy that's what's that's what's uh
crazy that
if you saw a picture of these dudes
that's holding up the movie
i know what they look like yeah man
um speaking of uh friday because i know
i can't keep you forever
it ties into uh uh good day
uh in as much as uh uh you know
uh of course our our heroes and friday
are preoccupied with weed i mean this
good day
oh look at that [ __ ] i had a they you
know since i mentioned earlier we share
a connection in caviar mike i got a box
of that [ __ ]
early and oh my god isn't it isn't it
great you do what it's supposed to do
right
yes it absolutely does how about that
friday i got that friday kush too
look at that [ __ ] what is that that's
that friday kush man
so i got the friday and the good day i
didn't have the friday night
oh that was a good day but i'll have
i'll have to go get you a box
i'll get it um i'll go down here bury
him and get it
when did it come out when did you street
like last month
uh i saw you i saw your billboard in los
angeles yeah
man i think we went out in february
leave february it was february
i don't lost track of time and [ __ ] we
haven't been cold
yes we have been in a pandemic uh
twilight zone
so what does it feel like to smoke your
own weed
it feel great i ain't gotta roll this
[ __ ]
the beauty of the preview you know we
work
i mean i'm pretty sure you know uh
my man caviar you know he he uh
i'm pretty sure i got on his nerves and
[ __ ] cause
you know i kept sending me back to the
drawing board and [ __ ] you know i'm
saying too it was
it was perfect to my to my taste you
know we we [ __ ] around for about a
year
coming up with just straight yeah
getting it perfect you know
um and so i'm i'm more than happy with
it
you know everybody i give barely can
finish
you know you can't finish a whole one i
know you can't
it is i'm serious yeah they're pretty
they're they're pretty intense joints of
caviar joints if they're
if you're a stoner those are the joints
that you smoke
to get high because you know normal
flour will just you know give you keep
you level
but caviar the infused weed is like
it's it's just very intense i i took
this
oh i took my mine on tour with me when
we toured jay and silent bob
reboot and so i didn't i had it for
four months straight um and wasn't able
to mix it up with just plain flour and
stuff so
it's it's pretty heavy stuff
um it's there's something called the
caviar challenge where
you know if you can smoke one of their
joints all the way down in 15 minutes
you win like a thousand bucks or
something like that but yeah
it's nearly impossible um the uh
the good day i the na i thought it was
good day because it reminded me of
boys in the hood when you were like that
was a good day where'd you get the name
from
today was a good day yes i'm saying
that's like
today was a good day is one of my
biggest songs you know what i'm saying
if i don't perform that [ __ ] it'll be
hell to play
you know what i'm saying so i just felt
like
you know when you want to blaze and [ __ ]
you're trying to turn
just trying to turn it into a good day
so
you know to me it's just it was perfect
name
for the perfect product um
i was waiting to put the name on
something that was right
so you know good day and friday
it just uh you know i don't see
i don't think you could say that without
seeing my face
so you know that's that's really what
it's all about you know i mean making
sure that
it's a name people remember um and
people feel comfortable with
know that uh that i ain't just throwing
no [ __ ] out there that that is something
that i'm really behind
so yeah we just want to grow
what states can they get it in right now
just california
right now it's california nevada
oklahoma uh got there one more state
um florida illinois
no no not not that far this west coast
it's uh man you know i've been putting
it too much
no no i didn't watch too much smoking
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've been hitting this
too much
but we're in four states and uh
it's been it's been doing great of
course it's been going great
i mean it's it is like again they make
impeccable weed but like
you know you branding it makes a big
difference as well
we're in new mexico i believe that it is
new mexico
um you've got now you got like christmas
gifts galore man you know what
everybody's getting
for christmas they're all getting some
yeah today they're all getting some
some good day they'll be in the world
with that there'll be a christmas day
strain that's what everyone's getting
yeah yeah we need a christmas day
yeah it's it's an insanely uh wonderful
varied career you got man
they call people like you renaissance
men like you know it's you you could
have [ __ ]
just done one thing which you did
insanely well
to break onto the scene in the first
place to introduce yourself
uh to the world and then you just kept
diversifying you kept like going like
this seems interesting this seems
interesting
and followed a bunch of different paths
man which you know
as i'm sure you know but for the
audience at home that gives
somebody options you know like you can't
be defined by one thing
your definition is all the things that
you do at this point
to some people you'll always be a rap
legend to some people you're a movie
star um yeah out to some [ __ ] people
you're there this is the oh he's the
dude on the weed i smoke
yeah without a doubt you know it's uh
you know what i don't want to be as a
jackalope trades master of none
you know i don't want to be that pretty
good at all of them though so so far i
mean i won't do it unless i
i know i could do it well you know so
um i do take advantage of
opportunities but only if i could do it
well because
one thing i don't want to do is
disrespect the game
and that's any game i get into you know
i want to respect the game
do what i'm supposed to do and work hard
and then the outcome should come out of
my favor
but so that's really what it's all about
is you know not just doing everything
but
seeing what you can do challenging
yourself learning the game
and then doing what it takes to to try
to be the best
and so um with that philosophy i've been
able to
to jump into a few different fields and
um you know i feel blessed
not everybody can do it listen
kids you've just heard the secret
you know everyone wants to know what's
the secret ice cube just literally laid
out the secret for you it's a treasure
map
follow literally what he said um and
you'd
be able to self-express um on some level
maybe not to the level he's reached but
hey you know it begins someplace like
you heard the man say
he didn't know they were going to be
racked in the front of the store let
alone
he was going to be a screenwriter let
alone he was going to be
an actor let alone he was going to be a
legend you directed already as well
right
yeah i directed a movie called the
players club yeah
i directed a couple of documentaries i
directed this [ __ ] for 30
30 30 espn uh you did one of those
welcome yeah uh it was uh
straight out of l.a i did straight out
of la which is talking about the
the raiders leaving la back in the day
um so you know i've done a few
things when it comes to directing it's
really you know
just about
you know making sure you take advantage
of your opportunities
um and
follow your heart stay creative you know
that's what i really want to say stay
creative
you know it it doesn't matter if you get
paid for it
just be creative because good things
happen
when you create when you're creative and
and
you also can get [ __ ] that's inside of
you
out sometimes putting it on the paper
writing it down
in a poem and wine and whatever
drawing painting uh sculpture
uh you know just being creative
opens opportunities on all kind of
levels so
that's what we was doing and look where
it's gotten me you know i mean just
being creative
you can't you ain't gonna get better
advice than that
all year kids uh and you got it from the
great ice cube man
uh ice cube thank you for taking the
time this was fun man
it's a good time man and again that weed
is fantastic
yo man we gotta do this again we will do
it again
you know you're gonna have to hit me up
with a couple of your back i
had a couple of your boxes i ran through
y'all need some more i know the feeling
i've blazed through yours as well
um that's it kids that's modcast for
this week i'm kevin smith
your boy ice cube um have a week
[Applause]
you